les français sont vaccinés à plus de 98%
contre le tétanos la polio la diphtérie
c'est à dire que pour certains vaccins
les français n'ont aucune hésitation
et si pour des vaccins plus récents il
ya plus de réticence s'est pas
totalement irrationnel il faut juste
l'écouté il faut il faut le convaincre
les français que ces nouveaux vaccins
apporte quelque chose je crois que dans
le cas du coronavirus si l'on à
certaines réticences
il ya une certaine il faudra les
comprendre par exemple quand vous avez
le camp des virus pour moi ce n'est pas
une maladie ces trois maladies
quand vous avez un corps navires us
avant l'âge de quarante ou cinquante ans
vous avez quelque chose qui est moins
grave que une virose respiratoires
commune
c'est à dire que c'est moins grave que
la grippe avant quarante ou cinquante
ans quand vous avez entre 50 et 70 ans
c'est une maladie qui est aussi grave
que ce qu'on appelait le sras en 2003 et
qui a tué 10 % de la population c'est à
dire que de la population atteinte c'est
à dire que c'est une maladie qui devient
très grave et quand vous avez plus de 70
ou 80 ans
c'est une maladie aussi grave qui est
beau la dent dans l'afrique de l'ouest
c'est à dire que c'est une maladie d'une
très très grande sévérité avec
malheureusement une très forte mortalité
et il faut se rendre compte que ces
trois catégories
c'est un peu plus compliqué il ya les
comorbidités qui peuvent aussi jouer
comme facteurs de risques mais quand
vous avez ces segments de la population
différents vous pouvez imaginer qu'ils
vont pas avoir la même perception sur le
risque et ils vont pas de la même façon
souhaité être favorable ou enthousiastes
pour le vaccin
si vous êtes un grand père ou une grand
mère et qu'on vous dit qu'il y aura
peut-être des inconnus à long terme
peut-être que ça vous gêne moins et que
vous êtes vous préférez pouvoir rpt et
embrassez vos petits enfants et vos
enfants et manger avec ea table bien
vaccinés si vous êtes quelqu'un de très
jeunes et que vous le sentez vous ne
risquez pas grand chose
eh bien peut-être que vous ne serez un
peu moins enthousiaste vous aurez envie
d'avoir un peu plus de recul
est-ce que c'est tellement irrationnel
de dire
[Musique]